في فقره خاصه نتطرق فيها مشاهدينا الى
الاسلحه التي تستخدمها قوات الامن
الايرانيه لقمعيه المتظاهرين حيث لم يتم
استخدام الذخيره الحيه بشكل كثيف خلال هذه
المباراه لكن تم استخدام خراطيش بنادق
عاده مخصصه للصيد على نطاق همم واسع
مشاهدينا جمال بالعياشي زميلنا من قسم
تحرير مراقبون اهلا وسهلا بك جمال
جمال همم قمتم في مراقبون برصد صور
لاستخدام البنادق وتم استخدامها لقمع
المتظاهرين الايرانيين طيله ثلاثه اشهر
الماضيات وهي من صنع شركه فرنسيه ايطاليه
ماذا اكتشفتهم وما هي التداعيات وهنا في
فرنسا
25 نوفمبر تشرين الثاني الماضي قمنا بنشر
التحقيق يك- يكشف بالفعل عن استخدام همم
خراطيش بنادق من صنع الاتحاد الاوروبي
لقمع المظاهرات في ايران وجماعه ايرانيون
صورا لهذه الخراطيش وقاموا بارسالها لنا
ونحن من جهتنا قمنا بالتحقق من صحتها
ستظهر لكم صور على الشاشه لهذه الخراطيش
فاذا لاحظتم هذه الصور ستجدون سترون عليها
علامه كلمه شديت والتظهر على القاعده
الحديديه للخرطوشه
وهذا ما يدل على استعمال هذه الخراطيش
خلال الاحتجاجات في ايران
كذلك همم انوه الى ان نشطاء ارسلوا لنا
ثلاثه عشر صور همم لهذه الخراطيش من مختلف
المدن وليس في موقع واحد علما ان هذا
النوع من الاسلحه يدخل تحت طائله عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي همم منذ 2011 و11 والتي
تقضي بمنع بيعها لايران
كذلك هذا التحقيق اثار يعني ردود افعال
ااا عديده في ايران حيث قام النشطاء ايييي
تداول التحقيق الذي قمنا بنشره
نعم
تحقيق الذي قمنا بنشره
وكذلك مثلا يوجد
منشور لاحد نشطاء الايرانيين يقول فيه هذه
هي الشركه الفرنسيه التي تقوم بتسويق
الخراطيش التي تسببت في فقه اعين العديد
من الايرانيين وبالفعل خراطيش من نوع شده
نعلم انها ليس من المفترض ان تكون قاتله
اذا تم استخدامها بشكل سليم اي همم من
مسافه بعيده ولكن تظهر مئات شهاده وصور
التي وصلتنا ان هذا النوع من الداخل يتسبب
في اصابات بالغه الخطوره حيث ان متظاهرون
اصيبوا بالعمى واخرون بعد اطلاق النار
عليهم من مسافه قريبه جدا
وكذلك يجب الاشاره الى انه يوجد غضب عالم
في ايران يعني بسبب هذا
المعلومات التي
نشرناها همم فمثلا هناك بعض النشطاء كتبوا
على الجدران في ايران على شكل جرافيتي هذه
الجمله همم التي تقول اذا اللقاحات
الانفلونزا محظوره بموجب العقوبات واعيرت
البنادق مسموح بها
همم
جمال هل هناك كذلك تداعيات في فرنسا
اكيد تحدثنا الى برلماني فرنسي وهو مقرب
يعني من
الاغلبيه الاغلبيه الرئاسيه واكد لنا انه
تم فتح تحقيق يعني في الموضوع وانه يعتقد
في رايه حسب المعطيات الاوليه انه لا يوجد
انتهاك لحظر
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعني لهذه الاسلحه
وبيعها لايران من طرف هذه الشركه
لكن من جهه اخرى اتحدثنا الى خمسه خبراء
مختصين في مجال العقوبات وجميعهم اكدوا
لنا ان قانون مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي يقضي
بحظر التصدير المباشر او غير المباشر
لذخائر والمعدات التي قد تستخدم لغايه
القمع الداخلي في ايران فاذا من المفترض
ان تكون هذه الشركه يعني مسؤوله
عن المعدات التي تصل عند تصل الى دول اخرى
حتى ولم تتبعها لها بشكل مباشره
[موسيقى]
ببيعها مباشره لايران ام هناك وسائط من
الممكن ان يكون وسائط يعني حتى الان لا
نعلم جيدا لكن همم حتى ولو وان لم تتبع
مباشره
هذه المعدات الى ايران فتبقى مسؤوله يعني
حسب القانون الاوروبي عند همم يعني هذه
همم الخراطيش التي همم تباع بطريقه ما
يعني الى ايران
شكرا جزيلا لك جمال بالعياشي شكرا